first what was the longest biz you did i
did a one and a half to four and a half
year bid for robbery in the third degree
what year was that this was in oh
six
and what did you end up i wound up i'm
only doing like 13 months because i did
the first first uh first time felon
program the shock program right where
it's like a boot camp type of thing
because when i was doing the whole fight
club [ __ ] battling mm-hmm i was on the
run i caught the case that i got locked
up for eventually i caught i was i did
it oh three wow i did a robbery i got
caught and uh i got bailed out and just
was like well i'm not turning myself
back and [ __ ] that and uh i started
doing the fight club i kept winning i'm
all over mtv [ __ ] is popping and then i
get caught
the judge was like yo
boom more than half the phone but she
said since you stayed out of trouble for
four years i'm gonna drop this to
non-violent wow so if it was if you got
rewarded for being on the run yeah
if uh if it would have stayed a violent
felony then i wouldn't have been able to
get that first time felon program but
because she dropped it to non-violent
the one that if you have nine years of
under they give you the chance yo you're
a first-time felon you do this this
shock boot camp type [ __ ] it's still
jail but it's like a boot camp you wake
up five a.m you gotta run work out
um and i was like i didn't want to do it
but i was like yo my career is just
starting to take off now with the
balance all over mtv every single night
i was like let me give it a chance if it
works out it works out if not so i ended
up doing altogether 14 months
came home on parole
stayed you know grabbed the wizonator i
had the wizonate at the time with the
fake piss
and uh that [ __ ] works huh absolutely